en dehors de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des surprises des confirmations le
second tour des municipales 2020 a livré
son verdict dans les yvelines à
rambouillet véronique mathieu tête de
liste de rambouillet ensemble vers
l'avenir va succéder à marc robert alors
remporté l'élection avec 46 84 % des
suffrages remercie profondément les
rambolitains qui m'ont marqué leur
confiance c'est vraiment un beau cadeau
qu'ils me font et j'espère être digne de
en tous les cas c'est comme ça que je
souhaite faire mon mandat est surtout
resté proche d'eux
de son côté le candidat écologiste david
jutier termine deuxième avec 37 0 6%
la déception la déception de ne pas
avoir gagné puisque c'était quand même
l'objectif numéro un
et puis un sentiment quand même de
devoir accompli vis-à-vis des électeurs
et électrices qui nous ont fait
confiance on a fait un score inédit à
rambouillet pour l'écologie politique
[Musique]
gilles schmitt candidat investi par la
république en marche termine lui en
troisième position avec 16 6%
oui c'est un échec je le prends comme
tel personnellement je prends comme un
échec
on n'a pas été capable je n'étais pas
dans la possibilité de en tout cas pas
capable de fédérer les heat aura que tu
nous fais d'habitude et qui nous fait
confiance à carrières sous poissy ville
de 6000 habitants eddie aït maire de la
commune de 2008 à 2014 récupère son
fauteuil
l'homme politique à l'étiquette
écologiste a battu le maire sortant
divers droite christophe delrieu avec un
écart de 518 voix
khadija gamme raoui termine 3e avec 18
points 44% à maisons-laffitte jacques
myard élu depuis 1989 repartira pour un
sixième mandat dans la cité du cheval sa
liste lr arrive en tête dans 15 des 16
bureaux de vote et totalise 45 91% des
suffrages
yannick guin divers droite termine
deuxième avec 37 84% à limay eric
rouleau est réélu maire avec 44,26 % des
suffrages le communiste devance la liste
divers droite de cécile dumoulin et la
liste divers-gauche du michael boutry
enfin vésinet le candidat lrm bruno
corps à des tiers et vend tête avec 32
points 54% des voix il devance la liste
et l'air de thibaut gripoix et les
listes divers droite de bernard grocaut
et françois bonneau